what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some pretty big news
about Loki season two when to expect it
and some new looks at some new
characters that have recently been
revealed that we're gonna dive into and
of course we have to talk about Jonathan
Majors as he is playing a major role in
Loki season 2 and just in the MCU in
general we have a little update on what
Marvel studios's plans are for Jonathan
Majors moving forward if they're going
to keep him or if they are simply going
to recast him obviously the studio is in
a pretty rough situation since Jonathan
may just got arrested and has been
charged with multiple accounts of
assault however Jonathan Majors
continues to this day and his lawyer as
well continue to say that he is innocent
and the truth will all be revealed when
he goes to court in a few days actually
and unfortunately due to this and some
other rough situations Loki seems to be
pushed back a little bit and everybody
has been wondering for a while now what
the situation is and when it's going to
be released so we'll talk about all of
that in including a brand new look at
some of the Loki season 2 characters in
this video and if you love Marvel be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you can always stay
updated on the MCU and so you can enter
our giveaway for a chance to win a Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends stuff
or some DC items winner gets to pick and
we pick a winner at the end of every
month so first things first the release
window for Loki because we've been
waiting on this it's got pushed back
already sadly it looks like it has been
pushed back again however we're actually
lucky to have some sort of a release
window and it have a release date at all
because apparently according to the
cosmic circus Marvel Studios had
discussions about not giving it a
release date at all and postponing it
indefinitely pretty much putting it on
hold until some other things kind of
panned out or kind of Simply went away
now of course we're talking about
Jonathan Majors the arrest of Jonathan
Majors all the charges against him
that's obviously something the studio
has to monitor very very closely that
has definitely impacted hacked of the
series as well as the rider strike and
just the general climate of the
entertainment industry right now so we
are lucky that Marvel Studios has even
decided on a release date and apparently
according to thecosmiccircus.com in
their report yesterday Marvel is iron
and October 2023 this year release date
now we were supposed to get the second
season for Loki in summer of 2023 so
basically it was supposed to be coming
out within a few months that was the
release date that was revealed during
San Diego Comic-Con where Kevin feige
revealed the entirety of phase five
sadly it's been pushed back a few times
and now it's landed on an October
release date so luckily for us if it was
going to be coming out in August it's
only postponed a couple of months
luckily it's not like some of the other
delays that have been six months to a
year and we do have some good news about
Loki season 2. evidently they are going
to air it with Jonathan Majors as king
and as his other variants we know Victor
timely is going to be one of them and
we'll probably see a few others pop in
as well according to the cosmic circus
dot com Jonathan Majors will still play
King and all of his variants in Loki
season 2. they're not going to change
that and I think there are a couple of
reasons for this one of course is it's
already been filmed they have filmed
everything so imagine going back to
re-film all of the scenes with Jonathan
Majors Kang and Kang variants that would
be a huge hassle to many different
people you have to bring back everybody
that was in a scene with him or scenes
and completely reshoot these scenes this
would essentially delay the release of
Loki season 2 by a year and the second
reason is if they decided to do this
then writing might have to be involved
again and right now there's a strike by
The Writer's Guild of America both East
and West So that obviously makes it
really really hard to do as well however
this doesn't mean that Marvel Studios
won't ultimately recast King the
Conqueror from what we've heard Marvel
Studios really is monitoring the
situation really closely and they are
going to be extremely careful in their
decision on whether or not to recast
Jonathan Majors as king I think
basically right now Marvel Studios is
waiting on the results of the trial for
Jonathan Majors but sources close to
Marvel Studios which have been reported
on by thecosmiccircus.com and some other
insiders like Jeff Snyder have stated
that Marvel Studios although they
haven't made any official decision
whatsoever whether they're going to
stick with Jonathan Majors or recast
they are essentially preparing for the
worst meaning that they are unofficially
thinking about who could potentially
replace Jonathan Majors as king the
Conqueror this isn't a light decision
it's a very big decision one that will
affect the entire Multiverse Saga we
don't know if Jonathan Majors is
innocent or not but he did bring a
certain power to the character on screen
he played Kang the Conqueror very well
and we were all very excited for him to
be the big bad of this Saga we were
excited for King Dynasty and Avenger
Secret Wars so if Marvel Studios
ultimately decides to recast that is
really big now according to Insider Jeff
Snyder Marvel Studios has had unofficial
talks of looking for an actor like
damson Idris he's a young and talented
upcoming actor but it doesn't mean they
will specifically choose him but
somebody kind of like him but again
until an official Court ruling has been
had Marvel Studios is simply waiting
until then and everything they have that
is filmed with Jonathan major so far
that is about to come out they are
simply going to leave that as is with
Jonathan major still playing King his
court date is in a few days so of course
we'll do an update video stating
everything that happens but before we
end this video we have a brand new look
at some promotions for Loki season 2
that reveal some pretty interesting
things and these came from well kind of
a leak on Amazon we have new promo art
revealed for Loki season 2 from Amazon
France we're unsure at the moment if
these are supposed to be released or if
they have actually been leaked but
either way we get us a new look at some
things coming in Loki season 2 including
characters who we still have no idea who
they are and this promo right here we
see Loki right up front of course played
by Tom Hiddleston we have Owen Wilson's
Mobius to the far left in what seems to
be some sort of a spacesuit we have
other looks at that as well that we're
about to get into in just a sec if you
look all the way on the right we have
won me masaku's character Hunter B15 and
on the right of Loki we have Eugene
Cordero who of course plays Casey from
Loki season 1 but then if you take a
look at the left side of Loki we have
the legendary kiwi Kwan and at this
point in time we don't know officially
yet who he is going to be playing in
Loki season 2. we don't know his
character it's also evident that Casey
is going to be involved in a bigger way
in Loki season 2. so we don't know much
about Casey and we don't really know
anything about kiwi Kwan's character
however we do know that these two
characters are going to be extremely
important in Loki season 2. in fact most
of the promos that have been released
have these two characters in them and
you typically only really promote the
main characters so that means they are
part of the main cast and they are going
to be important we have another promo
with them with low up top and on the
left is Owen Wilson again in an
astronaut suit we even have a soul promo
for Owen Wilson in this astronaut suit
with the TVA logo on the front so this
makes us think that Owen Wilson's
character Mobius is going to have to go
into space at some point in time perhaps
they go back into the past where they
have to get somewhere in space but has
kind of old technology not like
star-lord's face mask that just allows
him to breathe in space but they have to
use actual spacesuits to investigate
whatever they're looking for perhaps
Kang who eventually goes on to be he who
remains is building some sort of a base
in space and he has to suit up to get
there then we have another promo that
has the same five people on it again
stressing their importance and this one
it says the TVA has to change and it has
to start now now at this point we're not
really sure if this is some sort of TVA
propaganda if it's some sort of a sign
that is on display in the TVA somewhere
we're unsure Without Really any context
to this however this could mean that
Loki does break through to Mobius and
Hunter B15 and Casey and whoever kiwi
Kwan's playing and perhaps the five of
them actually managed to take control
over the TVA and tell them that hey it's
not as things seem you are all variants
we have to change and stop pruning
people while at the same time they still
kind of do have to prune timelines
because Kang is now let loose in the
Multiverse so they have to prevent a
huge multiversal war and we know from
the post-credits scene from Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania and the end of Loki
season 1 that Loki is absolutely
terrified of King we then have another
one that is just Loki and it says this
is bigger than the TVA this is about
everything now this most likely is just
promo this probably isn't in the actual
season anywhere it's probably just a
line that he tells Mobius at some point
in time and he's right because the
people at the TVA including Mobius
pretty much think that the TVA is kind
of the one above all they are above
universes they are above the entire
Multiverse they watch out for branch
timelines they prune them they're kind
of the almighty however Loki knows since
he met with he who remains that he who
remains and all of the king variants are
way bigger than the TV8 and that's
probably what this means by this is
about everything and it's bigger than
the TVA and of course last but not least
we can't end this without talking about
the new promos for Miss minutes Miss
minutes is going to be back which means
that she is most likely working for a
king variant at the end of Lucky season
one when Loki went back to the TVA it
was very clear that the TVA that he came
back to was not the original TVA where
he was before and this TVA has statues
of King which means it's ruled by King
so as expected Miss minutes is back
working for Kang yet again and I am
really glad that we finally do have a
release window hopefully it sticks to it
and it does end up coming out in October
if that stays true then we don't have
that much longer to wait so go ahead and
let us know how excited you are for Loki
season 2 in the comments down below and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and leave a comment so you can
enter our giveaway and of course stay up
to date on everything in the MCU don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
baby